- Als Gebäudereiniger muss man
sehr achten auf Sicherheit.
- Für Steigerarbeiten muss man
sich anschnallen,
bei Gondeln muss ich meinen
Sicherheitsgurt tragen und mich anschnallen.
Bei Leiterarbeiten muss immer
einer unten festhalten,
damit derjenige nicht umkippt.
- Wenn man mit Chemie arbeitet,
muss man aufpassen,
dass man die Dosierung richtig hat,
dass die Böden nicht kaputtgehen
und auch auf seine eigene Sicherheit,
das heißt, man muss Handschuhe tragen
und eine Brille.
- Sie müssen gut sein im Umgang
mit Kunden.
Manchen Objekte sind halt auch so,
dass die Kunden vor Ort sind.
Sie müssen freundlich sein,
sie müssen auf den Kunden
eingehen können,
sie müssen, wenn der Kunde mit
irgendeinem Problem zu ihnen kommt,
eine Lösung haben – sollten sie haben.
Aber dafür sind wir dann halt eben da,
um ihnen das halt beizubringen.
- Das Schönste als Gebäudereiniger ist,
dass man viel rumkommt,
dass man viele nette Arbeitskollegen hat
und dass man immer was lernt,
was man noch nicht wusste.
Also der Job ist nicht monoton.
- Ich habe keine Ausbildung gemacht,
sondern ich hab mich angestrengt,
Erfahrung gesammelt in 20 Jahren.
- Wir beschäftigen halt Mitarbeiter,
die keine Erfahrung haben
in der Gebäudereinigung. Die werden von
uns dann halt eingewiesen und angelernt,
dass man ihnen halt das Optimum
mitgeben kann,
wie eine Reinigung auszuführen ist.
Bei uns kann man auch eine Ausbildung
starten zum Gebäudereiniger.
Die Ausbildung dauert drei Jahre,
und danach hat man halt
eben die Möglichkeit,
als Bereichsleiter zum Beispiel
[zu arbeiten] oder halt selber
irgendwelche Häuser zu leiten.
Oder bestenfalls halt auch eventuell
sogar einen Meister zu machen
und den weiteren Schritt dann halt zur
Selbstständigkeit [zu gehen].
- Ein guter Gebäudereiniger muss
schnell und gründlich arbeiten.
- In meinem Job mach ich alles gerne.
Da macht mir alles Spaß.